so this you have to see that this is
just bizarre
um donald trump's former chief of staff
mark meadows a horrible person with no
morals whatsoever one of the biggest
liars and signal boosters of lies during
trump's administration
mark meadows went on newsmax's show
cortes and pellegrino
over the weekend and said that donald
trump
is he's he said president donald trump
is meeting with cabinet members to
talk about moving forward in a real way
what so in other words former president
donald trump
is meeting with people because he has no
cabinet
to talk about something that we don't
really fully understand i mean what what
does it even mean
meeting with cabinet members check out
this absolute and utter insanity
claire we've been here actually working
on uh
what comes next uh not only in 2024 but
how we win back the house in 2022 and
some of these state houses like virginia
so it's it's been a very productive
a couple of days i'm still here at
bedminster as you know
but wanted to to join you to talk about
uh really a president that is fully
engaged highly focused
and and remaining on on task
chief do you want to break any news from
your meetings with president trump
well we met with some of our cabinet
members tonight we actually had a
follow-up member uh meeting with some of
our cabinet members and as we were
looking at that
we're looking at what uh does come next
i i'm not
authorized to speak on behalf of the
president but i but i can tell you this
steve
uh we wouldn't be meeting tonight if we
weren't making plans to move forward in
a real way
with president trump at the head of that
ticket i like it well hey you can't you
can't blame me for fishing a little bit
there right
what is he talking about moving forward
in a real way
with president trump and his cabinet
like it's it's
the language implies that
meadows is alluding to some kind of
shadow presidency
a parallel presidency to joe biden or
that donald trump is
actually still the president that that's
what the language implies
it's possible that meadows is just using
weird language
and he just means the former president
is talking with potential cabinet
members
about a future run for the presidency or
something like that like maybe
that that would be a more sane thing to
be saying
uh or maybe mark meadows is referring to
this absurd idea of a reinstatement
that's been floating that's supposed to
happen in august by the way
it's august do we know what day it's
supposed to happen or maybe now it's
september which of course
it's not happening in august it's not
happening in september
if trump were more organized if you
heard
something like this from mark meadows
you might think whoa
this is almost starting to sound kind of
like pre-civil war
type rhetoric like he's talking about
some kind of takeover of some kind
uh you know i i don't know that trump is
actually that organized
the daily beasts molly jong fast had a
hilarious tweet about this
aside from like the absurdity of a
cabinet member
for a guy who's not even president molly
tweeted quote
trump didn't president when he was
president the idea somehow
that somehow he'd do it now is kind of
mind-boggling which is pretty on the
nose like
this guy didn't work for the last eight
months of his presidency
now we're supposed to believe he's
holding meetings and actually doing work
it makes up absolutely no sense
but understand that we see this you and
i i mean let's not you if you're
one of my trolls but you and i the the
figurative you and i we see this and we
laugh
and we say this is so bonkers but there
are
i mean millions there are tens of
millions of people
who see this and believe it 100 percent
some variation of trump is still somehow
wielding power
the military is under trump's control a
reinstatement is possible
the election results will be overturned
like not everybody believes all of those
things but you've got tens of millions
of people in this country who believe
some of that now in any case whatever
kind of moving forward
mark meadows is talking about hopefully
this time law enforcement
as well as intelligence agencies and the
military are
ready if moving forward is going to look
anything like it looked on january 6.
that's the concern from the standpoint
of public safety now also by the way
cabinet members i would love to know who
trump is meeting with and i don't mean
of course they're not cabinet members of
a shadow cabinet but what i mean is
by the end of trump's presidency even
much of his own cabinet
was pretty lukewarm about donald trump
the ones that didn't leave you know
people like
rex tillerson and others who left early
of course
they now are disgusted with with trump
maybe they were all along they don't
deserve praise for that it's just
hey you shouldn't have gone along with
it to begin with eventually they figured
that out
the ones that didn't leave i mean
you know like is is former secretary of
education
betsy devos meeting with donald trump in
florida or new jersey or wherever he is
like who is even meeting with donald
trump at this point
that's a really curious thing and the
best thing trump could do now you know
if trump really wanted to appear
as not a completely out of his mind
unable to accept reality child
there is something trump could do and i
would respect him for doing it
it wouldn't mean i would agree with
other things but i would say if trump
did this i would say
i respect that he did it even though it
would be for self-centered reasons
trump should record a psa one minute
video
no equivocation simply saying
my fellow americans this is donald trump
we must end the pandemic i got
vaccinated in january
the vaccine is safe it was developed
during my administration it was approved
by
my fda and it is time for you to do your
patriotic duty
for the maga movement get vaccinated
today we have all the vaccines we want
i need you to do me a favor though
remember that language
go and get yourself vaccinated it would
be one minute it would be super simple
it's the best thing trump could do for
the country and you know what in all
seriousness
it's undeniable that part of the reason
that more people haven't gotten
vaccinated is because
they see joe biden as the guy
administering the rollout of the
vaccines
and they are trump people and they
believe all sorts of horrible
things about joe biden okay so if trump
were to do such a video
a bunch of his followers would get
vaccinated and
trump could then accurately say
i am partially responsible for getting
these people vaccinated because i told
them to go and i did the psa
he would be right i would actually not
only respect trump for doing it
i would grant him these people are so
nuts
they weren't going to get vaccinated
until they heard it come out of your
mouth that they should go and do it in
in completely unequivocal terms
he could actually take credit for
something he is deserving of credit for
normally trump shifts blame away for
things he is responsible for
that he doesn't want credit for and
takes credit for things that have
nothing to do with him trump could do a
one-minute psa
it would lead to millions of
vaccinations not every i know not
everybody no not all of these people
will go and do it but
millions would and then he could
actually take credit for something
positive that he did instead
he's in this bizarre make-believe
portion
of his post-presidency delusional period
it's starting to get reminiscent of that
fred trump fake office that was set up i
don't know if people remember this
story that's been told um when trump's
dad
fred trump was struggling with serious
cognitive issues
uh basically it was almost like a set
his office was kind of turned into a set
in that he would have papers put in
front of him every day to sign
and stuff he thought he was working his
phone only went out to his secretary
he thought he was working but he really
wasn't he was almost it was almost like
the truman show in a sense
um great great film by the way uh that
that's that's sort of like what is
becoming reminiscent trump
trump's having a meeting and people sit
around the table like a cabinet but joe
biden's president it's starting to get
both
sad and disturbingly delusional
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has
twice the coverage of other shower heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it only took a few minutes
to set up
really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the showerhead starts at just 199
and you'll get 10 percent off all nebia
products when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is right underneath this video